Oh, okay. Okay. So, this is a church.
This is a church. There's supposedly the
pope is the vicor of Christ, right? He's
like, "I am I am Christ's representative
on earth. I take his place on earth. I'm
basically God." He says, "I am God." And
he's like, "Yeah." So, um, we got a
torture room back there. If you don't
agree with us, we're going to ask some
questions, but make sure you answer them
correctly, cuz otherwise you get
tortured. James, thank you so much for
being back here with us. Uh, some of the
videos you've been on with us here have,
praise the Lord, been one of our most
viewed episodes so far. So, that's
awesome. Today, you're talking about the
Vatican's library that you snuck into,
broke into, and you just found a whole
bunch of stuff. Now, I do want to
preface this with we are talking about
the Vatican in this case as the
Antichrist as identified in Revelation
13. And I want to say this, we
absolutely are not talking about people
here. We are talking about a system and
institution that the Bible talks about.
I was raised in a Catholic church. I had
to do the rosary. I I was going through
communion classes. I was partic
participating in mass. And so we are
absolutely not talking about beautiful,
wonderful, lovely Catholic people who
are part of the system. We are talking
about the system itself. So we have so
much respect for you if you are a
Catholic or know a Catholic. Um, but
please stay tuned as James exposes the
Vatican or we could say the Antichrist's
digital library and what you found
there. So, please James, what do you
have for us?
>> Awesome. Well, thank you so much for
having me. You know, the bibl
bibliotecha Apostolicica Vaticanana, uh,
it's a well-known library and it has
works spanning from approximately the
8th to the 20th century. They've
actually started digitizing these though
just recently as of 2010. So it's a
massive work. There's 80,000 church
cotices with 40 million scanned records
that they have to process.
>> That's a lot.
>> And you know what's interesting about
this is in times past these works were
kind of available to scholars only. You
had to show up. You had to present your
credentials. There's there's a long list
of things to to do to get access to
these. But now their access is available
to average people like you and I. And
it's an incredible opportunity to see
what the history has been showing up to
this point. So for those of you who
don't know, you can access it on DigiVat
Live right here. There's a way to search
and discover the collections right
there. They're actually filmed in such a
way that you have to open the volumes
carefully. Uh and
>> when they're filmed, there's videos.
>> Well, when when Yeah. When they
photograph it, uh they use a 50
megapixel Hustlebel camera to actually
digitize these. And you know when you
search the search engine, one of the
things that I found is that it doesn't
show everything right there. If you're
searching for a particular work, a lot
of these are not very well notated.
There's no optical character recognition
technology to be able to search
internally. It's very much a
painstakingly read read process as you
go through it. And for a lot of the
works, you actually have to consult
sometimes outside cataloges to locate
the work that you're looking for and its
reference number here and then find it
in the library.
>> So the search, are you searching in
Latin or are you just searching for
particular documents and their notation?
>> So sometimes both and I would say on the
Latin names even you have to be careful
there too because sometimes they're
spelled differently. For example, the
Inquisitor Rearius Psycho uh might be
spelled R E I N or in some cases R A Y N
uh depending on the manuscript. So there
can be textual variations and it really
requires kind of a dogged search process
to methodically locate some of this.
>> One of the tools that's made it easier
for me is a guy who's running a website
called Wiglaf and he's actually uh
notating a lot of these with the
incipits. Now, the incipit for those of
you who are not familiar with Latin is
kind of like an opening phrase in a
particular paragraph or work. And a lot
of times that initial letter will be
highly ornate and decorated, making it
very easy to locate the quote in
question. But he's got a lot of stuff uh
actually documented. As these come out
week by week, there are new documents
coming to light. And I'm excited because
a lot of them actually are demonstrating
the truth of what has been said in
Protestant works like this work right
here, The Great Controversy.
>> Link in the description for a free copy.
>> Okay. Wait, I have a question then. What
are they gaining by putting all this on
there?
>> I have to wonder that myself. And you
know, for those of you who are familiar
with like a court deposition process,
one of the tactics that uh is sometimes
done is when you're asked like for
transparency, you go and give your
opponent like boxes upon boxes upon
boxes of content and just overwhelm
them. In this case, it's not very well
referenced. But at the end of this, I
wonder if they can claim, you know, hey,
we've released all of our stuff. We're
not hiding anything.
>> Exactly. But really,
>> Too bad you can't read it. Yeah. Yeah.
>> It's not like it's not like you can just
type in their vicarious vibe which
references 666 and oh there it is.
>> Nope. Nope. You have to manually go
>> found it.
>> So um starting you know back at the
first century uh first second centuries
when you think about
the history of God's church one of the
things one of the documents that I first
became interested in or or I would say
chronologically uh is reggg.lat 900. It
actually contains Josephus discussion
about the abomination of desolation. uh
actually well he maybe didn't recognize
it as such but he some of his language
alludes to that where then came the
enens you got to think about this for a
second here when uh when you have
Cestius come and surround Jerusalem and
there's these enens this eagle at the
head of every Roman legion which seems
to them a signal of dominion and an omen
that they shall conquer all against whom
they march
>> how does this tie into you guys might
know this but how does this tie into
like the abomination of desolation with
Matthew 24.
>> You're talking about the wings.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, you know, the eagle was
very much uh became standardized on the
Roman standard and it was very much
associated with sun worship.
>> So, a lot of people think that the
abomination of desolation references,
you know, Antiochus Epiphanies and
events way in the past, but Christ in
Matthew 24 was talking about something
yet in the future. And so what I find
interesting about this is it's evidence
that there was this signal, this omen,
>> this sun worship standard that was set
up outside the walls of Jerusalem and
then Cestius for without a reason in the
world pulls back and Titus comes and
seals off the city. Everybody who saw
this abomination standing outside the
walls when Cestius pulls back for no
reason whatever goes and flees. But when
Titus comes back, he surrounds and seals
off the city. But guys, didn't we just
get an eagle made an official emblem of
the United States here recently?
>> Yeah, we did.
>> Yeah. And interesting, just a side note,
uh the eagle was also heavily used in
Freemasonry.
>> You know, this book, if you look at the
cover of it, it kind of has a mirror
right here of Rome and then a mirror the
or the main image of the United States.
>> It's no surprise then the the United
States is following Rome. Yeah. in kind
of making an image in many levels to
that ancient power right here.
>> Yeah. You're showing on the cover it's
the capital and it's the Vatican. Those
buildings are exactly the same. And
there's also the obs. Yes. That's in
both places as well.
>> Yeah.
>> And didn't the Nazis also use an eagle?
>> Yeah. Yeah, they did. Exactly.
>> Yeah. Oh, and that's interesting. We
watched a documentary recently on our
way to a conference in the car. uh you
guys bought this Adullum Films
>> and it was about the Jesuits and he
actually made the connection between the
Nazis and the Jesuits.
>> Yeah. They the Germans were actually
funneling large amounts of money into
the church because uh he he believed
that if you had the the church behind
you that all of a sudden you could win
the hearts of the people.
>> So he was kind of supporting them on the
background.
>> As we go through time, one of the things
that these documents show is kind of the
little bit of the state of the early
church. You know the early church uh
unlike the Catholicism of today actually
rejected things like the apocrypher for
example. We have Jerome who said let her
avoid all apocryphal writings and if she
is led to read such not by the truth of
the doctrines which they contain but out
of respect for the miracles contained in
them let her understand that they are
not really written by those to whom they
are ascribed that many faulty elements
have been introduced to them and that it
requires infinite discretion to look for
gold in the midst of dirt. Now um you
know obviously the church later kind of
folded and started to try and include
elements of the apocrypha but you know
it's interesting to me to see Rome
claiming that she's given the world the
Bible but if you go back and look again
on that Vatican digital library here is
the CEX Vaticanus right here it has
first Ezros 1 52 it's 55 in in some
notations if you if you look at it but
at this one it's 152 and they uh they
include this in the Vaticanus. It's
first Ezros in the Septuagen, which is
this manuscript right here, but it's
third Ezros in the Vulgate. And the the
interesting thing is is that the
councils of Roman Carthage affirmed
first Ezros as canonical, but they they
meant the Septuagent. They actually it's
defined as the Septuagent but then later
on when you get to Trent they affirm
first Ezros from the Vulgate
>> and there's a difference there and so
what's interesting about this is when
you get to all the way to Trent their
own encyclopedias indicate that the
canon wasn't actually clear all the way
up to the Council of Trent. So Rome
didn't even have an understanding of
what was canonical for a thousand years.
if you have to backtrack on on first
Ezros like that and say, "Well, no, we
don't mean first Ezros from the
Septuagent. We mean first Ezros from the
Vulgate."
>> And so, uh, they they state right there
that uncertainty that persisted up to
the time of Trent.
>> Rome did not give anyone the Bible at
least at least, uh, you know, God is the
one who has entrusted it to those who
have who have actually given it. But um
what we find in the early church,
Gregory the Great talked about the the
uh the bishop who called himself
universal would be the precursor of
antichrist. But that's exactly what
happened later on when you look at Pope
uh Gregory II right here, his dictatus
pepe. This is Vatlat 1321 where it
stated solus Romanus pontificales
or that the Roman pontiff is justly
called universal.
It's an exact fulfillment of what their
own pope said is the precursor to
Antichrist.
>> Wow.
>> Now guys, how long did the do we know
that the pope reigned for? For for
years, 1260.
>> Exactly.
>> That's cool, dude.
>> And what's interesting is that we've got
uh individuals like Flores on this
library testifying and beginning to
recognize that 1260 days was actually
not days, but it was years. 1,260 years.
Now, does that can that be applied to
Antiochus Epiphanies at all?
>> Mhm.
>> No.
>> No. He I mean,
>> no. And if you go back and compare, you
know, when it's talking about the
different rulers, it says, you know,
great, great, very great. And then you
get to Antakius Epiphanies and it's like
he's not great or very great compared to
somebody like Alexander the Great. Like,
he doesn't even compare. So, that's
true. To make that analogy doesn't work.
>> So, who is this guy and why was he
saying this? Well, Hakeima Flores was a
12th century, you've got, you know, a
bit of a theologian here who recognized
uh in his writings that, you know, they
were studying out the prophecies and
looking at these time periods and they
were beginning to recognize the dayear
principle. You know, this this is very
obvious when you look at Ezekiel 4:6 or
Numbers 14.
>> Yeah. A day for a year is in in
prophecy. So, if it says 1260 days, it's
actually 1260 years.
>> Yeah. And he wasn't actually alone in
this. There was a a 12th century court
physician who actually recognized the
benefits of a vegetarian diet and also
brushing your teeth. Arnold of Villanova
when studying Daniel 8:14 began to
recognize once again this day your year
principle that 2300 days is actually
2300 years.
>> So this was a common theme and again
another Vatican library document right
here where you can see right there D
intelligent anos. So by days we
understand as years. Wow.
>> So these were very much Protestant
principles now,
>> but they these were not they were
Protestant. They were not Catholics.
>> So you even had some Catholics, some of
these individuals were uh connected with
the Catholic Church, but began to study
on their own and recognize that there
were problems within Catholicism,
>> but but the Vatican has this in its own
library.
>> Yeah.
>> Why they have it?
>> They're exposing themselves.
>> Exactly. That's why my question is like
what what for what would they benefit
from putting this out?
>> Yeah, that's a good question. Um, but
you know, this book right here on page
50 recognizes that the pope has been
styled Lord God the Pope. And there have
been some people that have questioned
that over the years. We can actually
find it though in extravagantes of this
body of canon law right here. In this
case, the canonist was uh Zenzelinus de
Cassinus and it's written in the
margins. Um but obviously this was
reflective of other things like that
we've shown here previously like
distinctio 96 of canon law but he states
here to but to believe that our lord god
the pope the establisher of said
decretle and of this could not decree as
he did decree should be accounted
heretical. Now that gloss right there
domined
for years even in the aditio romano
version that was corrected by the pope
uh and it's available on UCLA's library.
There it is right there. the corpus
jurist canonichi or canon law. And you
can see right here that uh when Pope
Gregory actually printed the 1582
version in Rome itself, they kept that
particular statement in the gloss.
>> Mhm.
>> Referring to the pope as our lord god.
>> Wow.
>> And that was reflected in multiple of
these documents throughout the Vatican's
digital library. these arch cap sro
right here which uh interestingly enough
these these manuscripts right here have
the bulk of them have just been
digitized as of 2019. You can see
distinxio
uh this is distinctio 96 right here
where the is evidently shown that the
pope cannot be bound by the secular
authority called by the prized prince
Constantine God since it is evident that
God cannot be judged by man. Now in 2
Thessalonians 2:4, the Latin for the man
of sin is ostendenos.
The man of sin shows himself to be God.
What are the less bold like annotations
above or in between the lines?
>> Oo, that's a good question. So, some of
these are handwritten and uh I've I've
not had the chance to go through those
individual annotations right there
because a lot of these are are
handwritten and you'll notice that they
change manuscript to manuscript. So,
obviously somebody's come along and
added some personal
>> things are being inserted.
>> Is it kind of like you write in your
Bible, you know, just maybe a thought
that clarifies that.
>> Maybe
>> now ostendence, the word to show as God.
Notice the Latin word here in the law,
ostendtor.
That's the same Latin word that you find
in scripture.
>> And you know, another thing that they
elevated the pope to, we've got the the
donation of Constantine, which was a
forgery. Uh came out of the the pseudo
decorators or the Isidor uh manuscripts,
but um it became incorporated into canon
law. And you've got multiple examples,
those same sietro documents digitized as
of 2019 where the pope is referred to as
vicarious feli de. Mhm. And can you
explain for our audience what that
means?
>> Well, vicarious fil means vicor of the
son of God. The numbers add up. The the
Roman numerals add up to 666. Now, I
know some people have asked about the
subtractive principle, but actually in
the older uh Roman numerals, they used
addition um primarily until later on it
be kind of the subtractive principle got
incorporated. I would assume for the
sake of space and cost and everything of
writing out you know you don't want to
write MccC
xxx you know and and in long form so
instead of doing for example right here
we see x i I I I
that's additive that's not x iv so you
can see in the some of these older
manuscripts they use an additive
principle with Roman numerals.
>> Yeah. And what's interesting is you you
recently came in and we did a show on um
uh the Bale origins of 666 and how it's
connected to vicarious fa
and like you said if you add up
vicarious fa it comes out as 666 because
back in the day the letters meant
numbers right and the v and the u is
interchangeable. Yeah. Well, and think
about this too that the Bible in
Revelation 13:18 talks about adding up,
right? Add up the number of man up and
and it's the number like you said, it's
a number of a man and it is 666. So,
this completely fits. I have not found
anything else that fits that description
as perfectly as this.
>> I like how the Bible really clarifies
that it's a man.
>> This is not God. It's a man.
>> It's not a my code chip. It's not a
barcode. It is the number of a man. Um
and and yeah, and you were showing how
it's not just in some of their writings
in this episode, which we'll put a link
in the description. It's everywhere.
It's on their minor. It's on their
clothing. It's everywhere.
>> There's a little bit of confusion, too,
because the number of the man is not the
same thing as the mark of the beast.
>> Yes. Right. That's an important
distinctive point. The number just
identifies who the man is, but that
doesn't
>> it's not the mark.
>> Yeah. So, you know, you talked about
lots of documents. Well, take a look
here. We've got another copy, Vatican
Lat 1366, Vicarius Filadee. There's the
folios down at the bottom. Uh we've got
another one here, Vatlat 2493 or this
one, Vatlat 1368 right here. Secret Bis
Petrus in Teras Vicarius Fil. But also
some newer documents. This is Juan of
Torquamada right here. Uh Vatlat 2577
where the blessed Peter is said to be
appointed as the vicarious fil. Now,
it's interesting the word appointed or
constituted.
Constituted means to establish by law.
So, for anybody who doubts whether or
not this was an authoritative name, it
was constituted by law. And not only
that, but you've got uh you here's
another copy, a 12th century copy of
canon law, the decret gratani. You can
see vicari fi right there. Still adds up
to 666 even though the e for day is not
included there. It's written in
shorthand.
>> Interesting. But look at this document
right here. Um,
what kind of colors do you see here?
>> He's got a purple and scarlet on him. We
we've pointed that out in in in a few
shows with like different modern
characters that they're portraying as
purple and scarlet. But that's
fascinating.
>> Yes. So, if you understand this is
Revelation 17, I believe it talks about
the the harlot woman. I mean, we have a
whole video on this on our channel.
Again, link in the description where you
can see for yourself that again this
woman with purple and scarlet or red
refers to the the Vatican.
>> Just type in purple and scarlet and
church and just see what kind of images
come up.
>> Absolutely.
>> Yeah. It's interesting here that you see
kind of these colors almost matching
right here. Um the the image up at the
top there, but you got a dragon on the
front and then in this canon law the
pope's established as Vicarius Vad. Now,
I got a question because we we we
clearly don't have dragons in our world.
Why would you doodle a dragon on here?
>> It makes me think about Revelation,
right? You know what I mean? Revelation
12:9.
>> Like like are they admitting that they
are that?
>> It's an it's an old it's an old kind of
thing. You know, if you think about it,
you know, Revelation talks about the
dragon and and essentially it's this
idea where we get these fairy tale
stories of a man coming on a white horse
to save the woman,
>> right, and from the fury of the dragon.
Like all those fairy tales are really
modeled after what's in Revelation. Mhm.
>> So I think it's a
>> in people's minds it was like a common
story or mythology and that might be
>> you know uh I know somebody's going to
ask though but what about a papal
official official authoritative
statement but we found John the 22nd let
yuksta doctrina it's an apostolic
constitution right here that the emperor
Constantine testified saying the blessed
Peter is seen to have been constituted
vicarious film from this it follows
self-evidently that Peter can be called
the supreme head of the universal
church. And we've got another one here,
a letter by Pope Leo I 9th in Terapox
Hinibus that was delivered to the east,
you know, back in 1054 when the west
split from the east. One of the
arguments in that was actually over
Sabbath fasting. But um this letter was
delivered and they established the
blessed Peters seem to have been
constituted vicarious fade. So to the
pontiffs who having been granted by us
in our empire. So there it is like an
actual handwritten
document reggg.lat.413
part 2 folio 263r. It's available on the
Vatican's digital library.
>> Wow. And also in that picture is that
the pope is that Pope Leo
>> I believe so. Yes.
>> Yeah. You can see his miter or his
whatever you call that hat um with
triple crown
>> triple crown which was a reference that
they reigned over the sky, the earth and
the waters below or something like that
like three different realms which if you
look at the fourth commandment the
Sabbath commandment you pointed out in
this other episode about 666 that this
is actually God's territory and they're
saying I am God on earth and they're
they're taking that over this that uh
territory. So Daniel 7 warned about a
little horn that would think it has such
authority to change times and laws. And
take a look right here. Pope Gregory the
9th in his decret says that the pope is
said to have a heavenly power of
determination and therefore changes the
nature of things and that his will
stands for law and that he can set free
from the obligation of the law and that
he can make just that which is unjust by
correcting and changing laws.
>> Boy, have they done that.
>> Which is so opposite of God because his
laws don't change. He can't change it.
The law is immutable. And so
interesting, that's an argument that
Lucifer is using against God that, oh,
it's just arbitrary and if you wanted to
change it, you could change it. Right
now, he's placed a man in that position
and and he's like showing you he can
change these things.
>> Yeah.
>> It's interesting if you read the Latin
Vulgate for Daniel 7:25 because when it
says change, it's it's mutando or
mutate.
>> That's the same Latin word that they use
right here.
>> Interesting.
>> God's law is immutable. Like you can't
it's his it's like his character. You
can't ask God to change his character.
>> So they say here for not man but God
separates those whom the Roman pontiff
who exercises the functions not of a
mere man but of the true God having
weighed the necessity or benefit of the
churches dissolves not with human but
rather by divine authority
but also that according to the fullness
of power we can dispense above the law.
>> Remember 2 Thessalonians 2:4 says
exaltth himself above all that is called
God
>> or that is worshiped. Yeah.
>> So, this is interesting as you're
pointing this out because if you look at
the the ten commandments, right? Um the
the ones that are in the Bible, the
Roman Catholic Church actually changed
the ten commandments. For one, they're
admitting that they have changed
Sabbath,
>> the seventh day of the week to Sunday,
the first day of the week. They
literally use that terminology. It's the
first day of the week.
>> But also, they have taken out the
commandment. Yeah. number two that you
shall not make any graven images because
that's what they do. And then they split
up one of them so that they can make 10
again.
>> Yeah. They split the 10.
>> They split the 10th. Yeah. So there you
go.
>> It's that's a perfect transition because
you know the catechism actually goes so
far as to identify Sunday as a sign of
his universal benefits beneficence to
all. So, we see this idea of where God
establishes the Sabbath as a sign or
outward mark of obedience in in Exodus
31:17,
you know, but we can see right here
where this church comes along and
mutates that law, changes God's times
and laws exactly as Daniel 7:25 says,
>> cuz we're all the way back at the Garden
of Eden. We've come full circle. God's
trying to separate the people like, "Are
you going to do this because I'm asking
you to do it?" those that remain to to
worship on the day of the seventh day
Sabbath, let that be a sign that these
are my people. And and it's like the
test is coming down to this thing where
it's like they're they're changing it.
And then they're being like, look, if
you join our side, you know, then you're
not listening to God. And that's just
that's that's what's come full circle.
It's fascinating this last sentence.
Sunday worship fulfills the moral
command of the old covenant. So you see
how they're linking. And then it goes
on, taking of its rhythm and spirit in
the weekly celebration of the creator
and redeemer of his people. He put that
in context with what Revelation 14 is
teaching. And here God is making this
call. Why is God making the call in
Revelation 14 to be worshiped as the
creator
>> because it's not happening
>> in large degree. Otherwise, God wouldn't
be putting that message out there. And
he says, "No, no, no. Something's wrong.
You need to come back to what true
worship is all about.
>> Yeah. And also why why does this fourth
commandment says remember because people
are forgetting to keep the fourth
commandment. I mean there is no biblical
evidence that the Sabbath has been
changed to Sunday. But they're literally
saying we changed it. In u the entire
New Testament the Sabbath the the first
day of the week Sunday has been
mentioned eight times. Five of those
time those times it's the same event.
That leaves you with three more time.
Four more times.
>> So it's it's yeah it's eight total
texts.
Five of them are the same event. So
essentially you only have four separate
events that are being talked about.
>> Yes. So basically that's that's that's
it. That's how often the Sunday the
first day of the week is mentioned in
>> the New Testament. And just look up how
many times the Sabbath is referenced in
the book of Acts alone. I mean, there is
literally no evidence for this.
>> Notice too that they admit right here
that it's a moral command and not a
ceremonial one.
>> I'm sorry. Do we know each other? It
seems like maybe we've met before. I
don't know. This is uh it's awkward
though, just as much for me as it is for
you. I really wish I had a conversation
starter.
[Music]
Oh, hey. Oh, what's on my shirt? This is
the story of the three angels message
from Revelation 14. Wow, that totally
worked. You know, if you have trouble
starting conversations like me, maybe
you should try LightWare.
[Music]
What's interesting though is even on
this library there's evidence from works
like Thomas Aquinas that the precept of
the declo describes in the Sabbath the
exterior worship of God is a sign of the
universal boon that concerns all. Now,
Thomas Aquinus is actually the one
that's referenced in that previous
catechism uh link right there because
they're referencing Thomas Aquinus
trying to establish Sunday as this
different sign or mark. Now, Aquinus
went on further to attack God's law,
stating regarding the decalogue that the
essence of justice which they contain
are unchangeable, but is to any
determination by application to
individual actions, they admit of
change, sometimes also by human
authority, namely in such matters as are
subject to human jurisdictions. For in
this respect, men stand in the place of
God.
>> Wow. And Thomas Aquinus was also
connected to the Jesuits which is a free
um which is a secret society that was
created to destroy Protestantism.
>> Now Aquinas went on to go after two
other commandments of God's law. For
example, the principle we see this
reflected in 2408 catechism 248 where um
that if the need is manifest and urgent,
it is evident by the present need must
be remedi remedied by whatever means at
hand. For instance, when a person is in
some imminent danger, there's no other
possible remedy, it is lawful for a man
to sucker his own need by means of
another's property by taking it either
openly or secretly. Nor is this properly
speaking theft or robbery. But even
further, that secrecy is sometimes a
cause of sin, as when a man employs
secrecy in order to commit a sin. But in
in this sense that secrecy because it's
a sign of shame and removes scandal
diminishes the sin.
Now I I got to ask you guys if we can
steal when there's extreme need and even
do it in secret. What does that look
like when the world starts falling
apart? When there's natural disasters
that come,
>> there's going to be a redistribution of
the wealth and your property is not your
property anymore.
>> Yeah. It's total chaos and anarchy. Mhm.
>> I remember um you guys have heard of the
book A Thousand Shall Fall.
>> Mhm.
>> So, um I've read it a couple times. It's
so good. It's about this Christian guy
who had to go into the army of Hitler
and stuff, but he wanted to stay true
and faithful to his God. Anyway, while
his wife was at home, um the Nazis came
and knocked on her door and they asked
her some kind of a question and she
taught her kids, "You shall not lie even
in these kind of circumstances." And God
just worked it out that she did not that
the kid did not have to lie and they
said the truth. But in that moment, I
think somebody started giggling or
laughing out of nerves and the Nazis
were like, "Stop playing with us,
whatever." And they just left, you know,
they were lying.
>> No, they were telling the truth, you
know.
>> I think uh I think if I remember
correctly, the one of the questions was
like, you know, do you have any Jews
here? And rather than saying, you know,
no, it might not have been that one or
another story similar that I heard.
>> Oh, it might be Cory Timone. Cory
Timboom, let's pronounce it the Dutch
way
>> where it was like, hey, you're free to
look.
>> It was her. It was her.
>> Yeah. And then and then um they just,
you know, they just walked away.
>> So you don't have to lie. Like you can
trust God.
>> That's right.
>> Yeah.
>> And you know there's there's other
statements here. For example, this one.
Every cleric must obey the pope even if
he commands what is wrong for no one can
judge him. The only exception was if the
command involved heresy or tended to the
destruction of the church. Now these
claims to authority became so
pretentious John the 22nd commissioned
this work by Augustine triumphus the
suma de potlasia
where the pope was established or or
once again reiterated to be vicarious
viide. This was an official
authoritative commissioned book by the
pope, but also that he had authority
among other things, the changing of the
Sabbath day to the Lord's day. You can
see actually they have multiple copies
of this work available on the website.
And here's another one right here where
you see that the the Sabbath day being
changed into the Lord's day. Now,
Protestants had to react a bit to all of
this, right? I mean, there's a lot of
blasphemy taking place here. Um this is
a 14th century work that they have
digitized as well from Francisco
Petrarch where he says vengeance must
fall on thee thou filthy of
Babylon thou breaker of Christ's fold.
>> Thou from acorns and from water cold are
rich become with making many poor.
>> It goes on but it's quite a testament to
where individuals rightly recognize long
before 1517 that something was wrong in
Rome.
>> Yeah. It's interesting that they call it
the of Babylon because if you read
prophecy, this un unfortunately this
church is is referenced in the Bible as
Babylon. And in Revelation 17, it's also
considered the And in the Bible,
a woman is representative of a church.
And there's actually a faithful woman in
prophecy, a clear a clean woman uh who's
dressed in white who is representative
of God's faithful church. And then the
unfaithful church is considered the
of Babylon.
>> You know those those unions of church
and state power. Dante himself described
the church of Rome mixing two
governments that illort hath missed her
footing fallen into the meer and there
herself in burden much defiled. So there
were individuals recognizing that this
union of church and state had really
caused a lot of defilement. But there
were also and this book talks about it
right here faithful individuals like the
Waldenes. And you can see right here
this inquisitor Rereius Sakos stated
that they say that the Roman church is
the church of the wicked, the beast and
the harlot which are described in the
apocalypse.
>> And so you can see where Protestants
began to recognize this fulfillment of
Bible prophecy. Now these Waldenes uh
they were thought to be apostolic. We
see right here that Reer Sako states
that they say that the church of Christ
subsisted and the bishops and other
prillets down to the time of the blessed
Sylvester and in him it fell away until
they themselves restored it. Uh he has
another work specifically against the
Waldenes where he talks about the the
dangers of them. One of the dangers
being that some said that they were from
the apostolic time. And he states that
nevertheless they assert that there were
always some who feared God. this remnant
going back to the time of Christ and
were saved and they say that infants are
saved without baptism. So this has been
a widely debated topic like the Baptists
have tried this for a long time to say
hey there is this there is this
alternate line going back to the time of
Christ and here we can see evidence of
that that these people rejected infant
baptism. They were very much Anabaptist
in their roots.
>> And that fact is actually as a side note
here testified in their own pros over in
Trinity where they stated that the third
work of antichrist consists that he
attributes regeneration of the Holy
Spirit unto the dead outward work
baptizing infants in the faith.
>> So that's a work of antichrist. But the
seventh work is that antichrist
maintains his unity not by the holy
spirit but by the secular power. In
other words, a union of church and
state.
And you know further that the eighth
work of antichrist is that he hates,
persecutes and searches after and
despoils and destroys the members of
Christ. Persecution. Now in the Vatican
digital library you can see this
reflected here where they say the same
thing about the secular power this
inquisitors talking about these wild
entities. namely that it is not lawful
to punish evildoers with princes and
powers. That it wasn't the it was not
consistent with the gospel of Christ who
taught that my kingdom is not of this
world for if it were then would my
servant fight. M
>> it's interesting too though the sad
reality is these individuals faced a lot
of persecution and we're finding
inquisitorial registers where the
interrogations and persecution took
place against these people
>> and that's also a key uh to Revelation
>> where it talks about it's a persecuting
power.
>> Yeah. This is uh an example right here
of of one individual who you can see how
he actually was was threatened and he
actually responds to his inquisitor that
if the roles were reversed
he he would have the same matter of
conscience concerning denouncing a
heretic or or believer. He said that
those who persecute them are doing so
because they're preserving the truth of
the gospel. If if the roles were
reversed, he would not put an obstinate
heretic to death if he had that power.
>> In other words, they didn't the true
individuals didn't believe even if the
roles were reversed of using power to
persecute,
>> right? Because God's God's, you know,
he's never forceful like that. You know,
that comes from the enemy.
>> Yeah. Guys, if you can think back to
Daniel when he faced persecution, what
kind of example do we have in Daniel
chapter 1, there was a test that
occurred over diet first, right?
>> Yeah.
>> What kind of diet did he have to eat?
>> Pulse.
just like yeah plant-based.
>> I find it interesting that there's
actually evidence that the Cathars they
believe that to eat meat, eggs or cheese
even in pressing need is a mortal sin
and for this reason that they are
begotten by coition.
>> So who are these people?
>> So the Cathars were another group of
heretics around that time.
>> Heretics meaning they were Protestants
that didn't follow the Catholic Church.
>> Yeah. Well, some people have have
claimed that they were gnostic duelists
and and whatnot, but um I would say some
of the primary evidence from that from
their own writings is not as strong as
as some people say it is. But
nevertheless, they um they believed that
to eat meat, eggs or cheese was wrong.
They actually held to that Daniel one
diet. Um but further these individuals
like the Weldensians, the Pasagans, they
actually kept the 7th day Sabbath. And
you can see right here where Moneta,
this inquisitor's work on the digital
library states, "What shall not the
church give up her time on the go Lord's
day to attend to the gospel which leads
to perfection?" Against this, the
heretic objects, namely the Catherine
and Waldenses, which is found in
Galatians 4:10. M
>> so they're arguing against the Roman
Catholic Church's ability to establish
days of worship contrary to the law of
God. Now the pasans prepentus of Cremona
states that to the above the foreset
heretics add concerning the observance
of the Sabbath to prove which they lean
in this way.
>> That's a dragon at the bottom, isn't it?
A little little drawing.
>> Yes. Across each page of this work at
the bottom. One of the things that I
found interesting is there's that dragon
again blowing flames.
>> It's red and purplish.
>> Exactly. What?
>> There it is.
>> I mean, maybe they only had two colors
to work with, but
>> still that is fascinating to me.
>> Yeah. Yeah, it is. Um, but Bonursus was
another uh inquisitor who said, "Not a
few, but many know that the errors of
those who are called Pasagini, they were
called Pasagini because they were
passing through like different areas.
They were very mobile and um they teach
that we should obey the law of Moses
according to the letter, the Sabbath and
circumcision and legal precepts still
being enforced. Now, some uh evidence
later on suggests that they uh they did
not actually practice circumcision, but
that they were 7th day Sabbathke
keepers.
>> I'm still just mind blown that this is
in the Vatican's library.
>> I mean,
>> I want to know how many nights you've
laid there reading through these things.
>> Do you sleep?
>> Yeah, it's sometimes. Just just thinking
about they're like they're already
admitting in their own documents over
and over again. Yeah. So we changed the
Sabbath to Sunday. And then they have
their Jesuit books which you you have
Jesuit books. We have a whole episode on
that. You can look in their own Jesuit
books which is their own sacred society
uh and and find out what they wrote. But
then they have all this stuff about like
the Sabbath and like they're basically
their opponents that the Protestants
that they were trying to destroy and
turn back to their own church. They're
like, "Oh yeah, so these people are
saying this."
>> Yeah. You in one respect you might be
surprised, but on the other hand, they
don't think they're wrong.
>> Yeah.
>> And they don't think they're doing
anything wrong. So for them to put it
out there isn't like
>> it's not an admission of guilt.
>> Not on their part.
>> They're almost proud of it. Well, this
is what we did and
>> yeah,
>> you know, and we have the authority to
do it. So,
>> and if you are a Protestant, this is
what they say. If you are a Protestant,
why do you keep Sunday? You're supposed
to keep Sabbath. And if you don't, then
you just follow the our pope. That's
what they say.
>> And I suppose they have to explain why
they are on this side of the fence on
that topic because if you don't explain
it at all and then you require it from
the people. So, they have to actually
verbalize it in some way, shape, or
>> Yeah. But I wonder how many Catholics
there are very, very beautiful, honest.
Yeah,
>> genuine Catholic. I've met so many of
them. They were the most loving people.
I wonder how many of them know this.
They probably don't. They're not going
to the Catholic church on Sunday for
mass and they're like, "Oh, so by the
way, the Bible says you're supposed to
keep Sabbath, but we change the ten
commandments to Sunday and all that."
They don't hear that.
>> Here's a challenge. Just look it up.
Look, like do some research on your your
own. Like
>> I mean, you say that, but don't they
have to go through a catechism to become
Catholic? And isn't that addressed in
Catholicism? I mean, they have an
answer. So it's not like they're going
into it completely blind.
>> Yeah. So maybe they are hearing about
the Sabbath changed to Sunday, but they
just hear like, well, it's,
>> you know, it's it's Jesus resurrected on
the Sunday and the first day of the
week, so we changed it. Which is why a
lot of
>> Protestants,
>> it's not just that, though. It's also
the way their entire organization is set
up because they're not going with like,
well, the Bible's our only authority.
Now, they're saying the church has
authority that's equal to or above the
Bible. So, and if you believe that,
>> then their logic flows.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. You know, there's uh there's a lot
of evidence against these heretics
though that uh that they kept the
Sabbath. A heretics at least defined by
Rome
>> Protestants. Yeah.
>> Right. And you know, Rome's answer to
this is that we are informed by the
texts of the gospels that in this church
and in its power are two swords, namely
the spiritual and the temporal. This is
unam sanctum. And so, you know, they're
pushing this And this ultimately
resulted in a lot of persecution for
these individuals. You can see right
here this uh this register right here
that he said that he and those in his
order were an object of scorn before all
men for the name of Christ, but those
who sustain the faith until the end will
be saved. These Protestants recognized
that they were being persecuted for the
name of Christ. And as far as due
process being granted them, it came down
to this that, you know, he'll be
interrogated on telling the truth about
the Inquisition formed against him and
then he will either confess or deny.
There wasn't due process that was
granted to individuals like they weren't
able to face their accusers. They were
just, you know, either affirm this or
deny. And it's interesting because you
can find some of the the manuscripts
right here that testify to individuals
like John Wickliffe. Here's John
Wickliffe. You can see his name right
there and some of the uh concerns that
were brought against him. Here is the
Catholic cannon on dealing with heretics
from the 12th Lateran Council Lateran 4
where they state we excommunicate and
anathematize every heresy that raises
against the holy orthodox and Catholic
faith which we have above exclaim
condemning all heretics under whatever
names they may be known. For while they
have different faces, they are
nevertheless bound to each other by
their tales. Since in all them vanity is
a common element, thus condemned being
handed over to the secular rulers of
their baiffs, let them be abandoned to
be punished with due justice. Clerics
being first degraded from their orders
from as to the property of the
condemned. If they are layman, let it be
confiscated. If clerics, let it be
applied to the churches from which they
receive revenues, suspended, condemned.
And you know, ultimately if you were
excommunicated, that was essentially
like a sentence of death
>> because anybody could go and kill
excommunicated persons.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. We're going to take a look at that
here. But Aquinus rejection of religious
liberty, heretics, as soon as they're
convicted of heresy to be not only
excommunicated, but even put to death.
>> Yep.
>> I mean, makes sense. I mean, if the
church has already eternally damned
someone, what is you killing them gonna?
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. I mean, this is so wild. And we
know that millions and millions and
millions of Christians, literally
millions, have been murdered by this
institution during the dark ages.
>> Now, some people have said, you know,
well, how real was that Inquisition? And
one of the things that you'll find if
you go and type in the Nicholas Amar's
director inquisitorium on the Vatican
digital library, you won't find it. Not
very easily. You actually have to know
what manuscript you're looking for. And
here's one copy. It's Vatlat 486.
>> Censoring happened back then.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. This one's Vatlat 4866.61st
question is whether the bishop and
inquisitor can expose someone to
questions under torture and the
indications and causes derived from.
>> Oh, okay. Okay. So, this is a church.
This is a church. There's supposedly the
pope is the vicor of Christ, right? And
he's like, "I am I am Christ's
representative on earth. I take his
place on earth. I'm basically God." He
says, "I am God." And he's like, "Yeah."
So, um, we got a torture room back
there. If you don't agree with us, we're
going to ask some questions, but make
sure you answer them correctly because
otherwise you get tortured. What?
>> But a lot of people's view of God is
that
>> that's true. So if your view of God is
already warped,
>> you know, and the church is doing the
same thing, it just kind of follows
naturally from the logic that already
exists. I'm not saying it's right. I'm
just saying the picture that they paint
is con is consistent with that picture
that, you know, they've put out there
like getting people to believe that God
is a certain way.
>> Well, um that that's also where does
that picture come from, right? like it.
Yeah, it comes from this. But if you
understand the history, I love the
documentary that Amazing Facts put out,
Revelation, the bride, the beast in
Babylon. Link in the description. You
should absolutely watch this. It's
mind-blowing. You can see in there how
the ro the Roman Catholic Church came
into existence and it was literally the
pagan beliefs of the Romans that got
mixed with some Christian beliefs and
then it got you know it started meddling
and and that's how it came about. But
that's where these kind of beliefs of
like just god that just burns you in
hell forever and ever and he stands
there with a pitchfork and he's going to
burn you and and purgatory and if you
don't do good enough you make sure you
pay up because otherwise you go burn
some more. Like all of that is pagan
beliefs. It's not biblical.
>> So question 61 goes on to state that
prlets and inquisitors may put any
persons to the question by torture. that
it is laudable to torture those of every
class who are guilty of heresy and
common fame and one witness are
sufficient to justify the torture.
>> That's rough because the Bible doesn't
even teach that.
>> Yeah. It's it's got to be in the mouth
of two or three. Yeah.
>> Torture.
>> And you know this goes even further. So
it says that the whole city must be
burned on account of the heretics who
live in it and that whoever pleases may
seize and kill any heretics.
>> Peer pressure.
>> Yeah. Now, if you are interested folks
in seeing more, I'm going to refer you
to the American textbook of popery,
which uh it's available on archive.org,
but there's a lot of other statements in
here about the pope has the power over
infidels may make war with infidels. Um,
monks and priests who contract matrimony
shall be suspected of heresy. There's uh
statements like no person shall favor
the heretics. Positive laws bind not the
pope. Every individual may kill a
heretic. All of these are documented
with page numbers for a later reprint of
Nicholas Amar's directorium
inquisitorium and all of this you can go
back and find in those Vatican
manuscripts as well. Now you talked
about the numbers of individuals who who
have been persecuted.
A lot of those documents have been
suppressed. But what we're finding is
there's there's works like deh heresy uh
documents of the middle inquisition that
are being digitized now that have
thousands of individuals and the names
and the reasons why they were persecuted
actually being exposed now publicly for
everybody to go and see.
>> And what what reasons did you find?
Well, um, obvious obviously a lot of of
trumped up stuff doctrine that was
alleged to be counter to Roman
Catholicism. Um, you know, if you denied
some of these some of these central
doctrines that the papacy establishes,
then you would be, you know, uh,
suppressed and and ultimately uh,
tortured. For example, uh, you know, if
you rejected infant baptism, that was
one example. We've talked about Dirk
Williams before who was persecuted for
that reason. Um, but it got so bad that
Rome ultimately took individuals who
were guilty of homicide, sacrilege,
robbers of other people's rights, these
were criminals, and put together, as you
know, the crusades.
And the saddest reality here is that,
you know, the ultimate thing that the
devil really wants is to have people go
and kill in the name of God.
>> Okay? And so there's this there's this
uh statement right here. You wish to be
mindful of your souls. Either lay down
the girdle of such knighthood or advance
boldly as knights of Christ and rush as
quickly as you can to the defense of the
Eastern Church. And that was in 1095
when the Crusades went forth.
>> Kind of reminds me of Suicide Squad
premise a little bit.
>> Yeah. If you thought if you thought you
were doing God's work though, there's no
end to that, what you would go through.
>> If you really genuinely thought God told
me to do this.
>> Yeah. But for those people, the
criminals, it's not about doing God's
work. It's about getting off scot-free
and, you know, writing a new ticket.
>> Yeah.
>> They don't care about God's work. They
just don't want to be condemned to death
anymore.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, I think this is the danger though
in in the Pope saying he is God and
people believing it.
>> Because if the Pope tells you, "Kill
that guy." You're like, you're God,
okay? And you have no scriptures because
the Catholic Church
>> has been suppressing the scriptures for
years. I mean,
>> this book warns about a union of church
and state like this that will happen
again. Now, guys, take a look at this.
This is once again a recording from that
uh statement by the Pope in 1095 going
forth the crusades. When an armed attack
is made upon the enemy, let this one cry
be raised by all the soldiers of God. It
is the will of God. It is the will of
God. Davis Folult. Now, I have right
here a picture of an arm with a tattoo
on it. Davis Folt.
>> Do you guys know whose arm that is?
>> No.
>> That is Pete Hegsithth.
That's the new guy that's being
established as the Department of
Defense. Ah,
>> so Trump's new Department of Defense
fellow on his arm is tattooed this Latin
statement that comes from this Latin
document, this speech given by the Pope
in 1095 that it's the will of God to go
and
>> that's why I'm telling you if you think
if you think you're doing God's work,
there is no end to that.
Now, uh, it went so far as to even for
the Walden seas, let alone, you know,
the the Muslims and whatnot, they should
be burned alive in the sight of men
committed to the judgment of the flames.
Here we have Pope Innocent IV, Kum
Adveris, Hereticum Pravitatum, where he
goes on to condemn the patines and other
heretics, which included the Waldenes
and others to be burned alive in the
sight of men. But further, Alexander III
actually made a prohibition against
entertaining or uh having any commerce
or business with these individuals. In
other words, you could not buy or sell.
>> Revelation 13.
>> Yeah. Right.
>> Yeah, it is. It is. But I think that has
a a biblical
basis in a form of truth that God was
setting forth. So, if you go back, you
know, in in um Nehemiah, and I can't
remember if it's nine or 13, but the
people are
um the merchants are gathering outside
the city gates and trying to entice the
people. You know, they're pedaling their
wares and stuff and Nehemiah basically
runs them off. He's like, "No, we're not
going to do this. You know, close the
gates. Don't bring anything in. Don't
let anything go out." And essentially
what he's saying is no buying, no
selling on the Sabbath.
Why? because it's supposed to be a
consecrated time for God. So this idea
of no buy no sell is actually rooted in
a positive way
>> in a relationship with Christ because he
wants to reserve that time where you're
not engaged in commerce. You're not
engaged in secular activity. No, it's
holy time set apart with your creator.
The devil comes along later and he says,
I can use that
>> this no buy no sell idea. We'll enforce
that in a negative way. Right? But God's
people are already supposed to be in
that habit once a week.
>> So you come to the time of the end
>> and devil comes around is like, I'll fix
them. No buy, no sell. You're already in
the habit of it. You're It's already a
faith walk.
>> Amen.
>> So instead of being one day a week,
>> now it has to go to seven days a week.
And God promises, I'll take care of you.
I've always taken care of you.
>> Amen.
>> It's also pretty hypocritical though if
if God's like, okay, no buying and no
selling on the Sabbath, right? or no,
no, none of these things because, you
know, we don't want anyone to work, but
then it's like you're going over here
and you're, you know, giving money to
somebody that's working, somebody's
working. So, it's like, you know, I
think there's there's interesting
circumstances, though.
>> So, guys, no buy, no sell. Obviously,
we're talking now uh about, you know,
something in Revelation 14 about the
mark of the beast and how that's going
to be enforced. But let's take a look at
where Protestants ultimately took this.
You know, in the sanctification of the
Sabbath, John Lavington states that we
read in Revelation 14 of a two-fold mark
of distinction. God says here he would
make the due sanctification of the
Sabbath to be his mark and badge or a
sign by which it may be known whether
any did belong to him or not. But you
know Thomas Tillum in 1657 recognized
the change of times and laws charged
that upon Christ which is the proper
presumption of antichrist is not this
the mark to change the saints
times. But George Carlo stated, "Is not
this the horrors of Babylon's mark to
change the saints times? And inevitable
it is the word in this case, remove from
me the way of living and grant me the
law graciously." We see Protestants
recognize the Sabbath being thus a sign,
a mark or badge to acknowledge God to be
their God. It follows that a neglect or
contempt of this day redounded to God to
to slight that was slighting God. to
profane that was to affront God
but also that this observation of one
day and seven was to be a sign or mark
or badge that they acknowledged and
worship the one God which made heaven
and earth.
>> Yeah.
>> So guys at the end of time when we see
church and state uniting
>> Mhm. When we see Catholicism coming back
into the mainstream and we see the
history of what she's done in the past
and see God's word that establishes the
Sabbath as the seventh day to be that
outward sign or mark of obedience and
Rome tries to establish a counterfeit
mark, a counterfeit sign.
>> It even says and it's a they say
themselves the Sunday is a mark of our
authority, the mark.
>> Everybody gets a mark.
>> The question is is which sign do you
wish? Who is your sanctifier? Is it the
pope or is it God?
>> If you want to look deeper into this,
>> definitely the book.
>> Yeah, get the book. Just link in the
description for a free copy though. You
know, you can read it online or you get
a physical copy. Yep.
>> So, well, James, thank you so much for
being with us here again. That was a
powerful message. Praise God for that.
For those of you guys at home, please
make sure you check out some of the
other episodes we've done with him and
also his brother, Alex, who's been on
the show a couple of times. uh they
brought in a whole bunch of books from
the Vatican and and from the Jesuits
which again is a secret society that uh
they just show you from their own
writings. This is what they say just
like he did here but then with physical
books. Make sure you check out the
episode and also watch the episode he
did about the origins of 666 and the
connections to Baal worship. It's
fascinating. And also make sure you
check out our episodes we did on um who
is the antichrist and and you understand
from a biblical perspective why we are
saying that the Vatican and the papacy
is the antichrist. Again I want to
reiterate we love Catholics. We are not
hammering on people and on Catholics.
Again I was raised in the Catholic
church. I had to participate in mass. I
had was given a rosary to pray with. I
had to go through the communion classes.
Um, so we are not at all wanting to
attack Catholics. There are so many
beautiful Catholics out there, but we do
want to talk about this as an
institution that the Antichrist is and
not about the people that are involved
who know nothing about this, who are
very genuine people. Please also make
sure you check out our episode about
what the mark of the beast is to
understand more about why we're talking
about the Sabbath and about the Sunday
so much. And James also did two episodes
that talk about how the Sabbath actually
changed to Sunday and how throughout
history biblically and historically, you
can see that the Sabbath was kept by
God's faithful people. So, thank you
guys so much for watching. Please make
sure to hit like, subscribe, comment,
let us know down below what your
thoughts are, and we'll see you next
time.
If you like this video, like, subscribe,
>> and hit the notification bell so you
know when we launch new videos,
>> and drop a comment below. and we'll try
to get back to you if we can.
>> What?
>> Say that again. No.
>> No. I don't know what to say.
[Music]